字幕: Emily Chiasson
校正: Wilde Luo
（音楽）
沖縄の離島に行ったときに
たくさんの漂着ごみを見つけて
あっ 拾わなきゃって思ったんですけど
あれ このゴミ拾ってどこに
持っていくんだろうって思って
で ホテルに持っていったら
まずいよなとか
えっ これ本当どうしよう
ゴミ箱ないし
誰かに聞きたいなと思ったけど
島に知ってる人いないし
誰も歩いてないし
あれ 私 モチベーションも
時間もあるのに
ゴミ一つ拾えないんだって
思ったんですよ
あ でも この時に 島の人に
ゴミの捨て方を習うことができたりとか
何かちょっとお手伝いしてもらえたら
この時の旅って全然違ったもんになったん
じゃないかなって思って
また来るねとか そういう
ようななんだろうな
友情とまではいかなくても
そういうあったかい思い出が
できたんじゃないかなとか
で 私ももっと島との心の距離が近くなって
島のファンになったりとか
そういう島との心の距離が近くなるって
きっと誰かに何かをやってもらったとか
自分が楽しかったっていうだけじゃなくて
自分も何か還元することが
できたなとか
島のために何かできたって思ったりとか
その向こう側にちゃんと受け手がいて
ありがとうって言ってくれる人がいたりとか
何かそういうコミュニケーションが
生まれたらもっとあったかい旅に
なったんじゃないかなって
で それがきっかけでこのお金を払ってゴミを
拾うっていうプロジェクトが始まりました。
で このプロジェクトのルールは簡単で
各氏のパートナーと呼ばれるお店とか
そういうとこに行って
500円を払ってグッズをレンタルします
そして分別ルールを習ってゴミ拾いをして
このゴミはパートナーさんのところに
グッズと一緒にお返しして で パートナーさんが
地域のルールに沿ってゴミ出しをしてくれます
あの 実はボランティアのゴミ拾いってすごく
複雑になるケースがあって
ほとんどの地域ではボランティアのゴミ拾いは
勝手に捨てるんじゃなくて
地域の自治体としっかり連携をとって
地域の自治体に手続き
しないといけないんですね
例えば 役場に電話をして
ゴミ拾いたいんですけどって言ったら
あっじゃあ申請書書きに来てくださいとか
で 申請書書いたら
ここにゴミをどこどこに
持って行ってくださいとか
分別はこうですよと分別間違っていたら
持ってきませんよとか
何時までなんとかセンターに持っててねとか
そういういろんなルールがあるんですけど
自治体にごみを拾いたいん
ですっていう受付をしても
塩対応されることもあるんですね
せっかくあの この地域のためになりたいんで
ゴミ拾いたいんですって言っても結構
面倒くさがられるケースっていうのがよくあって
でもその実情にはその地域が本当に
ゴミで困ってたりとか
役場の人数が少なくて回らないとか
そういう事情があったりします
でも せっかくのこの都市のために
何かしたいっていう思いの人が
そういう対応をされたら
悲しいじゃないですか
自治体に受付とかをせず ゴミを拾って
例えばビーチのそばに置いてちゃったりとか
あと雑木林において行っちゃったりとか
でもこれは善意でここに置けば
この地域の人が見つけて持ってて
くれるよねって きっと地域の人は喜んでくれる
ってそう思って置いていっちゃうん
ですけど でもこれって
何にもないところにいきなり
ゴミ捨て場ができたみたいに見えちゃうんですね
なのでそこにどんどんゴミがやってきてですね
新しいゴミ捨て場だって言って どんどん分別
されてないゴミが増えて増えて で そういう原因に
なってしまうっていうケースがとても多くて
だけど、この地元の人を通して受付が
できる このお金を払って
ゴミを拾っているプロジェクトもですね
活用すると
そういう問題がなくなるんですね
で 何よりも地域のために何か
したいっていう人が可視化できて
それに地域のために何かやってくれる人を
歓迎したいっていう人も可視化できて
そこに暮らしてる人たちだけではなくて
その外から来た人も
この地域のために何かできるんだよ
しかも簡単にそんなに時間もかけずに
できるんだよっていう そういう取り組みが
広がると たくさんのところで
優しさの循環が広まって
豊かな社会になっていくん
じゃないかなと思っています